the scorching temperatures will continue
this weekend as met office warnings
remain and temperatures continue to peak
well above 30 degrees in large parts of
the country
for now mediterranean-style landscape
and caribbean levels of heat mean the
risk of fire remains heightened this a
grass fire in raynham in essex
chris sparks from hampshire doesn't know
how the fire started in his yard
all right so it spread all through the
roof yeah
yeah then
good god but soon it had devoured a
bedroom wall and then his roof it's like
charcoal is gonna rain down on your
living room well yeah because what's
happened is
because
it was so hot it was just literally
falling down
the whole house is destroyed timber
frames charred
shoes melted
as is the television
yesterday a tractor caught fire here in
codford in wiltshire
fire risk is another setback in a
difficult summer for farmers
it's the emotional effect and it's a
stress
and it's it's also the danger to to
to human life and uh
our staff are very dedicated and they're
very keen to fight the fires and
sometimes we we have to
tell them to ease off a bit because i'd
much rather have a fire than a staff
injury
with some areas of the country not
receiving significant rainfall all
summer the national drought group
declared an official drought in eight of
its 14 areas of the country it means
more hosepipe bands and residents and
businesses being asked to conserve water
the important thing is that the water
supply remains resilient for this year
there's no no real issue there and these
are precautionary steps that are being
taken
to ensure that we're taking care of our
water resources in case we get a dry
winter and then run into potential
problems next year
people here at the flower pots pub in
hampshire say they do what they can
when you've got a garden you put quite a
lot of money into it and it's all shrubs
and you're sitting there with one
watering can but what i have been using
is old washing up water anything at all
is going into the garden at the moment
it's tough trying to be a bit more
environmentally friendly obviously where
the hosepipe van not using water having
showers
not using bath
in the west yorkshire penins a usually
submerged norse village has partially
reappeared
this centuries-old pack horse bridge now
stands as a worrying low water mark in
what should be an abundant reservoir
it's just another oddity in the new
landscape created by this extraordinary
heatwave jason farrell sky news